[Música]
os jovens sempre tão transgressores
ávidos por viver cheio de energia e por
vezes até meio rebeldes
não importa qual é a geração essa sempre
foi a sua essência mas se você sempre a
mesma porque quando eu era jovem eu não
sentia que a minha geração era uma dos
meus pais porque de hoje quando eu olho
para minha filha que tem dois anos eu
sinto que a geração dela não vai ser
como a minha
aliás porque diferentes gerações nasce o
que define uma geração é um grupo de
pessoas que nasceu em uma mesma época e
já passou várias fases da vida infância
a adolescência ea juventude compartilham
dos mesmos contextos sociais econômicos
políticos e culturais
isso significa que ele mesmo grupo de
pessoas viverão experiências e vivências
comuns que refletiam um comportamento
daquela época
vou dar um exemplo nos anos 80 eu ainda
era criança e os meus pais já estavam lá
adultos trabalhando cuidando da nossa
casa cuidar da nossa casa nossa casa
naquela época significava lidar com o
dinheiro numa época em que a inflação
que era muito grande esta instabilidade
econômica então era maior ainda
então basicamente quando os meus pais
iam até o supermercado
a ideia era poder comprar o máximo de
comida possível pra gente poder tocar na
nossa dispensa porque como dizia o meu
pai tinha que aproveitar o preço de
ocasião tão inclusive nesses mesmos
momentos quando a gente chegava no
supermercado e vi aquele funcionário com
o marcador zinho de preço eu tinha que
correr na frente dele é com medo que os
preços fossem mudar na mesma hora
então tudo isso toda essa vivência com o
dinheiro ela marcou meus pais com a
forma com que eles lidam com isso ea
forma com que eles lidam com o dinheiro
se reflete até hoje
ao mesmo tempo estava eu lá a criança
vivendo também dentro de si mesmo
contexto mas num outro momento de vida
onde pra mim que não fazia essas
conexões que não cuidava desse dinheiro
a única coisa que eu via é que de tempos
em tempos a dispensa da minha casa
ficava cheia de comida que eu adorava
então a forma com que eu comecei a lidar
com o dinheiro não é igual
forma com que os meus pais davam o
dinheiro e aí quando a gente olha então
para uma geração que já nasceu com o
mercado online
imagino que essa pessoa pensa em relação
ao conceito de dispensa
ela nem consegue entender o que isso
significa então que a gente está falando
de diferentes momentos de vida com
diferentes contextos que geram
diferentes comportamentos se engana a
gente quem pensa que uma geração nasce a
cada dez anos ou a cada 20 anos a chegar
uma nova geração não é por aí
cada geração nasce à medida que o mundo
muda e como o mundo já vi mudou muitas
vezes a gente viu já há algumas gerações
passaram por nós ea gente já conhece
três delas muito bem
a primeira delas são os baby boomers os
baby boomers foram que inauguraram
aquilo que a gente chama de jovens
digamos que antes deles a gente falava
que essas pessoas eram pessoas de pouca
idade
então eles é que inaugurar este life
style estilo de vida jovem o contexto em
que eles foram os jovens eram um
contexto de um mundo está muito dividido
pela guerra fria no brasil
a gente estava vivendo a repressão ea
ditadura
em função disso eles se tornaram jovens
que respondiam com um comportamento que
era muito revolucionário mas mais do que
isso é um comportamento muito idealista
aí de repente chegou a geração x a
geração x viveu um contexto da hegemonia
do capitalismo
alguns vão lembrar então aquela figura
do bancário aquela figura do rio pium
dos bancos
naturalmente esses jovens se tornaram
muito materialistas e muito competitivos
e muito individualista era geração
coca-cola e aí então o mundo mudou mais
uma vez a gente viu uma estabilidade
econômica chegar no brasil não era nem a
estabilidade econômica era uma ascensão
enquanto econômica a gente viu muita
gente crescer economicamente nessa época
e aí então chegaram os milênios ou a
geração y que foi uma geração que por
não se preocupar tanto com questões
financeiras teve muito mais tempo pra
questionar muito mais tempo para
questionar a forma com que a gente
trabalhava muito mais tempo para
questionar como a gente cuidava do nosso
planeta e muito mais tempo pra
questionar de como a gente se
relacionava entre as pessoas
tudo isso quer dizer gente que todas
essas gerações de alguma maneira elas
responderam a mudanças que foram
acontecendo no mundo
também provocaram mudanças em todos nós
independente da geração que nem sempre a
gente se dá conta de que isso realmente
aconteceu
vou dar um exemplo quem não lembra de
uma época em que a gente fala uma época
muito recente inclusive mas não pode
esquecer disse que a gente dizia que
rede social era coisa de jovem
esses dias a minha mãe da mídia assim
nossa tem uma coisa que eu não estou
encontrando mais o facebook a jovem é
porque agora eu só acho que minhas
amigas postando foto de neto de cachorro
convite pra achar ou tentando encontrar
uma colega que eu não vejo muito tempo
outro dia também não muito tempo atrás
acabei ouvindo sem querer a conversa de
uma senhorinha assim bem velhinha já
realmente era bem mais velho e ela disse
o seguinte
ah eu adoro usar o a tap porque o rap
zap eu posso falar horas e horas e horas
com quem eu quiser eu não pago quase
nada
então no final das contas a gente às
vezes não percebe o quanto realmente
todos esses jovens por mais diferentes
que sejam por mais que esteja
inaugurando novos comportamentos estão
mudando a todos nós e aí gente
a notícia é o seguinte há milênios
cresceram e agora a gente entra então na
quarta geração de jovens que é a geração
z
e aí todo mundo pergunta então qual é a
diferença dessa geração em relação às
demais né
o principal giro diferença que essa
geração tem em relação aos anteriores e
é que eles são nativos digitais
tenho certeza que muitos de vocês já
ouviram essa expressão por aí mas a
verdade é que a gente não nem sempre
sabe o que ela significa o porquê é que
faz tanta diferença geração ser nativa
digital
o fato é que essa é a primeira geração
que existiu até hoje que nunca viu
muitos a internet então os baby boomers
da geração x e os simpsons eles nasceram
numa num mundo em que ainda não tinha
internet ou seja quando ela surgiu eles
precisarão se adaptar a isso e é o
momento em que eles precisarão se
adaptar e começavam a ver essas duas
realidades como opostas nos dividir uma
realidade que era offline e real com a
realidade que era online
já para os nativos digitais ou pela
geração z
tanto faz se é físico ou virtual todos
eles são reais e não só
reais como eles são complementares que
isso quer dizer gente que por exemplo
quando se está num show
acho que praticamente todo mundo aqui já
foi um show com um dia a gente fica ali
olhando e de repente começa a ver
aquelas pessoas no celular
principalmente jovens é filmando
postando fotografando e aí sempre tem
aquela pergunta tá aí quando é que esse
pessoal vai aproveitar o show é vai
ficar todo mundo no celular
a verdade é que para essa geração aquilo
só tem graça de verdade está na rede o
que significa que estão lá curtindo sim
aquele show está acontecendo mas ele
fica ainda mais legal se com a
possibilidade de eu colocar isso nas
redes e não trocar só com os meus amigos
que estão aqui comigo no show mas também
com os meus amigos que não estão no show
que estão fora de lá estão interagindo
comigo e tornando aquela experiência
ainda mais legal
a júlia quero mandar meu afilhado
já faz um tempo é super geração z também
no meio chegou em casa e disse o
seguinte que uma mãe de uma menina dela
tinha colocado a amiga de castigo porque
ela passava muito tempo no computador e
precisava fazer amigos reais
os amigos que ela tinha um computador
não eram reais e aí prontamente julho
chegou em casa cheia de ironia
olhou pra gente disse o é então quer
dizer que os amigos que eu falo no
computador não são reais eles não
existem
o que eu quero dizer com isso né ajuda
sabe gente a diferença entre uma tela do
computador a tela de um celular por uma
janela onde ela vê os amigos ela sabe a
diferença entre eles
a questão é que ela não vê como coisas
opostas
ela entende que tanto da janela quanto a
certas da tela do celular é possível
desenvolver conexões verdadeiras é
possível fazer as conexões tanto
pessoalmente quanto através da rede e
mais do que isso é possível que eu
convivo com essas duas realidades ao
mesmo tempo e por causa disso
conecte muito mais informações e essa
fluidez que essa geração tem e se
conectar com diferentes mundos com
diferentes pessoas com diferentes
lugares que realmente colocam eles uma
fluidez muito grande de informações e
trocas faz com que eles também muda em
relação àqueles são como pessoa que isso
quer dizer que essa é uma geração
extremamente fluida em relação à sua
própria identidade
querem fugir o máximo possível de todo
tipo de estereótipo que existe quanto
mais autêntico eles puderem ser melhor
aí vamos voltar de novo lá na geração x
pra ver a diferença jovens dos anos 80
a gente vê aquelas tribos na super
fechadas aliás o jovem dos anos 80
adorava o estereótipo era punk era
grunge a nerd ou era roqueiro e esses
grupos eram super homogêneos e super
fechados então quem era punk sempre
falava como punk se vestia como punk
tinha uma posição política como bang
aliás o que jamais poderia naquela época
houve uma música pop ou vestir algumas
roupas coloridas agora para a geração z
é exatamente isso
a idéia é que você consiga flu ilação
aquilo que quer da melhor maneira
possível
quanto mais se delimita quanto mais se
determina mas você tá botando as
gerações dentro de uma caixinha então
definir pra eles é limitar a ideia é
tentar fugir
a maior parte do tempo esses votos não à
toa gente
essa é a geração que tem nos feito mais
pensar a respeito da fluidez de gênero e
também sobre sexualidade
eles entendem que isso é uma questão que
deve fluir de maneira mais natural
possível
mais uma história também considerando
algo assim estava recentemente um bar
com um amigo um barco cheio de pessoas
bem mais jovens do que nós
eu vi que estava incomodado e talvez lá
pelas tantas ele falou é um pouco
confuso com as pessoas que estão aqui
mas porquê dele sai um sempre são que eu
tenho eu estou dentro do meu filho do
instagram eo mas por que então ele me
explicou que na verdade quando ele
olhava para aquelas pessoas que se
vestiam de uma forma que ele não
entendia que um cabelo que pra eles eram
estranhos que o misturas que eles não
coisa que ele não conseguia compreender
a idéia que ele tinha aquelas pessoas
eram avatares anos como os personagens
online e que aqueles avatar estava
invadindo mundo físico e é mais ou menos
por aí gente
se o online e offline são a mesma coisa
então na forma com que eu sou online
também a forma de uso offline e todo
mundo convive do mesmo jeito com todas
as diferenças e aí é que vem
mais um dos comportamentos dessa geração
eles convivem com tantas diferenças
acabaram se tornando um radicalmente
inclusivos eles agem muito processo de
comunidade
se essa é uma geração gente que não quer
se limitar que não quer determinar
limites para quem eles querem ser eles
precisam ser compreensivas com todos
aqueles que são diferentes então imagine
a diferença que é em relação às gerações
anteriores por uma coisa em comum uma
causa em comum qualquer coisa em comum
eles esquecem qualquer diferença
vou usar de novo exemplo político de
baby boomers geração x
era preciso escolher um lado ou à
esquerda para direita ou era capitalista
ou é socialista ou era conservador ou
era libertário verdade que a partir do
momento que escolhi um lado você andava
com iguais com a geração z não é assim
com a geração museu possui uma pessoa de
esquerda que vão andar com alguma pessoa
de direita só que eu gosto de pop
coreano ou por que a gente é vegano ou
por qualquer outro motivo
quem aqui não conhece alguém ou talvez
inclusive foi essa pessoa que deixou de
falar com algum amigo ou bloqueou bem na
internet por aquela passou a ter falado
alguma coisa do qual você não concordava
essas são as gerações anteriores
a geração z não é muito mais tolerante e
muito mais próximo mas são muito
tolerantes em relação às suas próprias
relações interpessoais no que diz
respeito à vida gente a vida pessoal
eles são extremamente pragmáticos que
isso quer dizer o telefone é o celular
principalmente a tecnologia deu muitas
ferramentas para essa geração controlar
cada passo da vida
então tudo é muito controlado ao mesmo
tempo em termos de contexto eles viram a
casa cair
neris passaram por toda aquela
estabilidade econômica e de repente a
crise principalmente no brasil então
muitos deles viram os pais perderem o
emprego ea vida mudar dentro de casa e
fora de casa no mundo eles viram toda a
situação com os refugiados viram as
situações com terroristas
por isso são uma geração muito mais pé
no chão do que as gerações anteriores
hoje eles sabem que precisam investir no
agora pra conseguir construir um futuro
quando a gente olha para os milênios que
viveram aquela estabilidade econômica né
irão manter a uma preocupação menor no
que diz respeito às finanças
ele sim se tornar o mais questionadores
então vez não tinham tanta pressa em
fazer o futuro chegar porque as questões
eram outras
mas quando a gente fala da geração z
diferente agora é muito importante
inclusive existe uma certa dificuldade
de falar onde se imagina daqui a dez
anos porque o presente é que faz as
coisas acontecerem
o ponto gente é que nem pendente da
geração todas elas inaugurou um
comportamento e com a geração z não foi
diferente
o mundo se transformou uma nova geração
surgiu novos comportamentos surgiram
através da voz dos jovens porque são os
jovens que conseguem trazer essas
mudanças de uma forma mais natural ea
notícia é gente é que esses cinco são
infinitos
eles não vão acabar e ainda para se
tornar um pouco mais difíceis vão ser
cada vez mais rápidos porque à medida
que o mundo muda mais rápido mais
gerações vão surgir mais rápido ainda
e aí pela primeira vez na história a
gente convive com quatro gerações ao
mesmo tempo dentro de uma mesma família
e dentro de um mesmo ambiente de
trabalho ea pergunta que sempre fica é
poxa como é que eu vou conviver com isso
como que a gente se conecta então embora
existam sim muitas diferenças de
comportamento
existem muito mais semelhanças do que a
gente pode imaginar a verdade gente é
que eu acredito muito e acredito que
vocês vão concordar comigo existem
muitas pessoas interessadas em ver um
mundo melhor
interessado em ver a nossa evolução
interessadas em ver um progresso
essa é esse é o fim de todas as gerações
então por mais que as gerações escolhas
diferentes caminhos para se chegar em
determinados lugares a busca ea essência
é a mesma daquele mesmo jovem dos anos
60 e 70 dos anos 80 90 e 2000 e 2010 nós
mesmas
eu quero ver um mundo melhor só querem
ver as organizações familiares querem
ainda mais legais só querem construir
relações cada vez mais verdadeiras e
deixar um mundo cada vez melhor para
todo mundo
a questão é importante a gente conseguir
entender os caminhos escolhidos claro
que é importante
assim a gente se conhece mais como ser
humano
mas a verdade é que através da
similaridade é que a gente vai conseguir
mudar tudo por aqui pra frente eu
convido a todos na verdade é sempre
pensar em todas essas similaridades para
que a gente continue transformando e
principalmente evoluindo
todos juntos obrigada gente
[Aplausos]